[Music]
foreign
sure
[Music]
I used to spending friends
of my hometown
[Music]
repeat
coming up above
[Music]
foreign
viewers of this channel may have
recognized that statue in the background
that is the Buchanan statue at the tail
end of Meridian Hill Park also called
Malcolm X Park in the Columbia Heights
neighborhood of DC I used to live in
Columbia Heights and for several years
of my tech blog that's where I was
recording all my videos I since moved to
other parts of DC but they just
renovated and reopened that part of the
park so I thought it would be a fun trip
down memory lane to go shoot a float
video there now that the space has
changed a little bit so I hope you
enjoyed watching it real quickly thanks
to flow toys for sponsoring this video
and giving me an opportunity to go out
and shoot some cool flow videos in
places from Drex past if you'd like to
grab a set of those FPC pod POI that I
was using in this video you can do so by
heading on over to flowtoys.com and
using my special promo code drexfactor 6
2023 yes that is drexfactor 6 2023 my
code is recently changed that'll get you
a discount on your order and it helps
out the channel so everybody wins thanks
once again to flowtoys for sponsoring
this video and speaking of thank yous
big thank you goes out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrotire light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-business
friend of the channel That is Becca
backlonen thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
and finally this video would not be
possible we're not for the kind support
of all of these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people who sit down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support if you'd like to
check out some of my other flow videos
I'm going to go ahead and leave a link
to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you're watching on YouTube and also
the YouTube algorithm thinks that you
might like this top video here too so
maybe give that a look thanks so much
for watching make sure to like And
subscribe and I'll see you with a new
video real soon
peace